as millions of people were locked down
last year was a christmas party thrown
in downing street for dozens of people
on december the 18th
prime minister
[Applause]
mr speaker
what i can tell the right honourable
gentleman is that
is that all guidance was followed uh
completely during number ten and can i
and can i can i recommend uh to the
right honourable gentleman that he does
uh the same uh with his own christmas
party which he's advertised uh for
december the 15th for which to which
unaccountably he's failed to invite the
the the deputy leader uh mr speaker
[Applause]
nice try but that won't work mr speaker
the the defense seems to be the defense
seems to be no rules were broken well
i've got the rules that were in place at
the time prime minister of this party
they're very they're very clear mr
speaker
you
you must
you must not have a work christmas lunch
or party
does the prime minister really expect
the country to believe that while people
were banned from seeing their loved ones
at christmas last year it was fine for
him and his friends to throw a boozy
party in downing street
[Applause]
mr speaker i've said i've said what i've
said about uh number 10 and uh
the events of 12 months ago but he since
he asked about what we're asking the the
country to do this year mr speaker which
i think is uh frankly a more relevant uh
consideration
the important thing to do mr speaker is
not only to follow the guidance which we
have which we have set out but also when
it comes to dealing with the omicron uh
variant to make sure that as we've said
that you wear a mask in
on public transport and in uh in in
shops mr speaker and that you self
isolate if you come into contact uh with
somebody uh with somebody who has uh
omicron mr speaker and above all what
we're doing is strengthening our
measures at the borders uh but
particularly and i think this would be
uh very valuable for everybody to hear
uh get your booster mr speaker
i know that i know the right honourable
gentleman uh is eligible uh for his
booster i'm not going to ask you mr
speaker since i'm forbidden to ask him
uh questions but i hope very much that
he's had it
well i can tell the prime minister above
mine kirsten
mr speaker the prime minister says we
should concentrate on what he's asking
the country to do we're asking the
country to follow the rules now the
prime minister the prime minister
doesn't deny there was a downing street
christmas party last year he's not
denied it
he says he says no rules were broken
both of those things can't be true prime
minister
he's taking the british public for falls
and as for following the rules prime
minister
it might be good just to look behind you
when it comes to the question of masks
as ever one rule for them another rule
for everybody else
[Music]
mr speaker at the last election the
prime minister promised to build 40 new
hospitals 40 new hospitals page 10 of
his manifesto with waiting lists so high
prime minister it's a very very
important commitment
now the cabinet office and the treasury
have
checked on progress
and it's reported that they've reached a
damning conclusion i know the chancellor
has seen that they've concluded that the
project needs a red flag because it's
unachievable
prime minister
is that true
prime minister
no mr speaker uh we're getting on with
uh
he he plays politics and asks frivolous
questions mr speaker we're getting on
with delivering on the people's
priorities and and we're putting we're
putting record investments into the nhs
on top of the the 34 billion with which
we began and then the 97 billion that we
put in to fight covid uh we we mr
speaker are helping to build another 40
new hospitals with a an injection of 36
billion pounds of investment mr speaker
which that party voted against
well this is strange mr speaker because
the government hasn't been denying the
reports about the red flag and they
haven't done since but now the prime
minister does there's obviously there's
obviously some confusion on these
benches
over whether the cabinet office and the
treasury think he's on course to break
yet another promise this time on new
building of hospitals so he can clear
this up this afternoon if he's so
confident in his answer why doesn't he
publish the progress report in full and
let us all see it
prime minister mr speaker what we're
doing is not only building uh 40 new
hospitals but we are also but we are
also but we are also and it's incredible
uh that we've been able to keep going
throughout the pandemic but we're also
making record investments in our nas it
is and we're also making record
investments in our nhs we have more
doctors
more nurses working in our nhs than at
any time in the history of that
magnificent organization
and rather than rather than running down
what they're trying to do mr speaker
casting doubt on their efforts he should
get behind them and he should
particularly he should support our
booster campaign
well mr speaker there we have it i deny
the prime minister i deny my hospital a
building program has been flagged read
as unachievable but i don't have the
confidence to erupt to publish the
report
mr speaker the more we look at this
promise the murkier it gets
i've got a document here sent by the
department of health
to the nhs
it's called the new hospital program
communications playbook i kid you not
it offers
it offers advice mr speaker to make it
easier to talk about the program
now you might think that everyone knows
what a new hospital is
i certainly thought i knew what a new
hospital is
before i read this document but this
guide instructs everybody to describe
refurbishments
and alterations on existing hospitals as
new hospitals
we can all agree we can all agree that
refurbishments are a very good thing
but they're not new hospitals
so prime minister
how many of the 40 are fix-up jobs on
existing hospitals and how many are
actually the new hospitals he promised
prime minister
mr speaker you obviously
don't always go around building on
greenfield sites uh what we are doing is
what we are doing is
you you rebuild hospitals and that is
what we have said for the last two and a
half years mr speaker it is the biggest
program of hospital building this
country has ever undertaken it's being
made possible by this people's
government and it's in addition to what
we're doing with the community
diagnostics hubs mr speaker and it's a
it's in addition to what we're doing in
investing in our nhs and i i said it
once but i'll say it say it again they
had the opportunity to vote for that 36
billion they turned it down mr speaker
we're getting on with the people's
priorities they're playing politics
and no wonder so many tory donuts paid
so much for that wallpaper last year it
probably told me it's building a new
flat
it's the same old story from this prime
minister week in week out defending the
indefensible and broken promises his
mates were found to be corrupt he tried
to get them off the hook
downing street throws parties during
lockdown he says not a problem
he promised to be no tax rises then he
put up tax
he promised to be a rail revolution in
the north then he cancelled the trains
he promised no one would have to sell
their home for care then along came his
working-class dementia tax
he promised 40 new hospitals and even if
you count the paint jobs his own
watchdog says he can't deliver it
isn't this the truth mr speaker that any
promises from this prime minister aren't
worth the manifesto paper they're
written on
mr speaker
the right honourable gentleman the right
honourable gentleman dribbles on
dribbles on irrelevantly about uh about
wallpaper and parties uh playing
politics uh and by the way on that i'm
told i'm told that when the deputy
leader and shadow secretary of state for
the future work was told that she wasn't
invited she denounced it she'd announced
it as idiotic childish and pathetic mr
speaker
they're getting on they're getting on
with factional they're getting on with
factional infighting we are delivering
for the people of this country today
today
today cutting tax for the lowest paid
people in this country one as a result
of our universal universal credit
changes 1.9 million families getting a
thousand pounds more in their in their
paying habits this year the biggest
program of rail infrastructure this
century mr speaker three new five-speed
lines and we're fixing social care they
have no plan whatever mr speaker and
don't forget don't forget their their
resort to absolutely every problem is
either to take this country back into
lockdown or to open up to uncontrolled
immigration dicker that is that is that
is their approach we are delivering on
the people's priorities and and we have
more people in work now as a result of
the balanced and proportionate approach
that we are taking than we had before
the pandemic began and if we listen to
him mr speaker if we listened to captain
hindsight we'd all still be in lockdown
and that is the truth